[Music]
happy Halloween everybody let's talk
about Halloween - the 1981 original
sequel to John Carpenter's horror
masterpiece this film picks up right
with the original left off Laurie played
by Jamie Lee Curtis is being taken to
the hospital and Michael Myers is still
out there stalking a bunch of other
teenagers and dr. Loomis is still on the
hunt to try to find him
I shot him six times I shot him in the
heart he's not human and has a warning
to anyone who has not seen this film
this review is gonna contain spoilers
this movie feels like a logical
continuation of what John Carpenter's
set up Rick Rosenthal the director did a
pretty good job of emulating carpenter
style a lot of really creepy wide shots
even though they had a bigger budget to
work with it still feels suitably low
scale which is something I really like
about this movie there are more graphic
kills there's more makeup involved with
some of these kills there's clearly more
extras an actress to work with but it
still feels like a smaller film which is
something that was so great about the
first Halloween because it felt like
such a tiny little movie that exploded
into something gigantic and since they
had a bigger budget to work with they
could do more things with the story like
Michael Myers walking around in a crowd
of trick-or-treaters in a Halloween mask
with blood all over him that's not
strange on Halloween night and so he
blends in and when a young kid named Ben
tramer shows up in a similar outfit he
is targeted by Loomis and eventually is
killed in a motor accident and I like
that they explored that and they could
have gone even deeper with that the idea
of looking for one guy in a Halloween
outfit amongst a crowd of people who are
also dressed up for Halloween Carpenter
once again did the score this time
around this time collaborating with
Allen howarth
and it's a pretty good update he didn't
remix things too much he didn't change
things that much I have it on vinyl I
often play it for Halloween parties I'm
also a big fan of creep
abandoned hospitals there's something
about some small-town Hospital that's
pretty deserted in the middle of the
night that's extremely scary to me
one of the major criticisms of Halloween
too is that it's far more glory than
carpenter's original interestingly Rick
Rosenthal filmed it to be more subtle a
lot like what carpenter did apparently
carpenter underwent reshoots and re shot
a lot of scenes to up the gore factor
much to rick Rosenthal's dismay I guess
carpenter felt that because of all of
the films of Halloween inspired like the
Friday the 13th movies and other slasher
films that if they didn't up the gore
factor it would be considered not scary
enough this I think was a really poor
choice and one of carpenters worst
decisions because it was one of the
major criticisms of the movie and it
does kind of make some of the characters
feel like disposable bodies eventually
waiting to be killed which is pretty
much the big thing you ever hear from a
critical standpoint of all slasher
movies characters aren't characters
they're just walking mannequins ready to
be killed in gory ways
Halloween 2 may have been the first big
film to start that because the first
Halloween obviously had a lot of deaths
but they were off screen or the gore was
very minimal this film went way to over
the top with it close-ups of needles and
eyes burning women alive and hot tubs
and while watching it today it feels
almost tame compared to other horror
films that have come out since I can see
how at the time people would have felt
that way
there's also too many randoms walking
around exploring this empty Hospital of
waiting to be killed and that's one of
the side effects of that trend where we
have to have these really gory deaths
and we don't want our leads like Laurie
or dr. Loomis to die so quickly so let's
have a bunch of random people get killed
and there's a little bit too much of
that it kind of drains the suspense
because you're just waiting for the kill
you're not as invested in the scene and
sometimes this movie can have that as a
major flaw because it doesn't set up the
sequences as well as it could kind of
like the way final destination movies
really try to get you to wait and
paid how someone's going to die this
movie just has characters exploring dark
corners of hallways and you're just
waiting for Meijer to eventually pop out
and kill them there's also an attempt to
create a backstory for Michael Myers
here a reason for why he can keep
getting shot over and over again and
continuously get up in the first film he
was basically evil personified that was
the theme of that movie it tries to hint
that Michael is something else possibly
supernatural it doesn't come out and say
it but clearly after being shot multiple
times in the first one and multiple
times in this one something else is
going on with Michael Myers beyond the
idea of him just being evil and it
worked just enough in the first film
where he felt so terrified by his
presence he felt like this unstoppable
force also this film relies very heavily
on the knowledge that you have seen the
first there is very little setup for
what has gone on before it this film
benefits heavily from watching the first
and then this one back to back it's
pretty much the best way to watch
Halloween - almost like an elongated
miniseries but it's also a flaw because
it does really nothing to setup Laurie
Strode character and she's basically in
a hospital bed for most of the movie
until she's once again running from
Michael Myers so as a standalone movie
it definitely doesn't work and it really
requires you to watch both back to back
and that's easily the best way to view
this film also there's a lot of
off-screen kills that don't really make
sense like this one doctor or nurse with
an IV set up to drip blood out of her
for a very long period of time there's a
lot of moments like that where you're
like what exactly was Myers doing during
this movie when he's stalking through
these hallways is he also going to an
elementary school and writing samhain on
a chalkboard for the viewers and for the
cops to find like there's a lot of
things that feel like added story
elements at the last second to explain
his backstory and to have more gory
kills beyond those flaws Halloween too
can be watched as a fun follow-up from
the first it is very suspenseful I think
it's a very well directed movie in
regards to the visual look of it it
captures John Carpenter's feel very well
there's a lot of very creepy wide-shots
Michael
meir still really works as a villain and
Donald Pleasance as Lumis is once again
like the heart and soul of this movie
whenever he's talking about his past
experiences with Meyers it's very
exciting and Halloween too has always
been a bit of a guilty pleasure for me I
have a lot of issues with it from a
story perspective but like I said it's
best viewed when you watch the first and
this back-to-back and in so doing you
can have a fun Halloween night and I
respect them for actually ending this
story and for not having yet another
Halloween movie with Michael Myers they
did try to do something different next
year we're gonna be talking about
Halloween 3 as well as every single
other Halloween movie leading up to the
new Halloween I'm gonna review one
Halloween film a month starting in March
I believe leading up to the new
Halloween film and yes that's including
Halloween resurrection and the - Rob
Zombie Halloween's but all that being
said I'm gonna get Halloween to a B -
it's better than most of the horror
sequels in franchises that started at
that time it's far better than Friday
the 13th Part 2 leaps and bounds better
than Nightmare on Elm Street part 2
which I really don't like this is a
perfectly enjoyable Halloween movie and
it did its best guys I did want to do
more videos with my wife we had planned
to do this review together and
trick-or-treat but unfortunately she is
down with the flu and a really bad ear
infection she's had it for almost two
weeks now and so we weren't able to film
anything together so I just want to let
you know that's why after child's play
it was just me she wanted to do more but
she's been really sick guys thank you so
much for watching this fifth annual
Halloween special I had a great time
talking about tons of horror movies with
you and as always happy Halloween and if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]